the jurogan experience now daryl i want
to talk to you about your personal
experience on minds with this uh with
what you what you do what you're known
for have you had interactions with
people on minds that have been favorable
that if you've kind of pushed people
into uh i've had yeah i've had a few and
i've had you know my share of detractors
so people think you know what i'm doing
is totally wrong and don't get me or
whatever but yeah i've had i've had
interactions with some people
when so when you say like people said
it's totally wrong like what what what
kind of criticisms do they have for that
uh it depends upon where they're coming
from um some people think it's not my
job to teach white people how to treat
us
us mean black people
others think it's ridiculous to sit down
with a white supremacist why you know
why why would you waste your time uh you
know those people can't change do you
point to your success ratio because it's
pretty amazing yeah i point to that you
know but a lot of people you know they
don't see that because they don't they
would not tolerate the time to sit down
right and have somebody tell them some
nonsense that jews are the childs of the
devil or you know some crazy yeah things
like that uh i will sit and listen to
that and i will put up with it
uh because in order for me to
uh speak speak my mind i have to listen
to somebody else's yes right so they're
not willing to to put in that time i am
yeah and so
when
how do you have the time to do this this
is what i do you know in between my
music gigs yeah but i mean like that's
what kind of commitment are you talking
about like how much time do you spend
doing this a lot i mean it's my life now
how many like email dialogues oh god i
get i get emails all the time i give you
emails from people i don't even know i
even get emails from people who've seen
me on podcasts or on tv shows these are
white supremacist clansmen whatever and
say you know you made some sense in it
would you like my rope i've even gotten
robes
in the mail from people i don't even
know yes yeah i think there's a lot of
sad people that just need a group of
people to belong to and they'll decide
that what these people are saying make
sense because at least they'll be a part
of it let me explain something to you
one's percep as you already know one's
perception is one's reality okay
you cannot change anybody's reality if
you try to change their reality you're
going to get pushback because they only
know what they know whether it's real or
not it's their reality so what you want
to do is you want to offer them
a better alternative perception and if
they resonate with your perception then
they will change their own reality
because their perception becomes their
reality just a quick example let's say
you got a seven or eight year old
brother right and he goes to a magic
show with his buddies and he comes back
and tells you joe you know this magician
he asked for a female volunteer and 50
women raised their hand he picked up
this one come up on stage he told her to
climb into this long box and stick her
feet out that hole and put her head out
this hole and then he closed the lid
told her to wiggle her feet and she
kicked her legs and they took a chainsaw
went
and cut that box in half he cut that
woman in half and you're like uh
it didn't really happen like that yes it
did i was there you weren't even there i
saw it with my own eyes you are
challenging his reality he knows what he
saw
and that magician cut that woman in half
and then to make it even more uh obvious
to you he tells you that the magician
after you cut the box in half took the
half with the legs sticking out and
moved it over here stays right and the
half with the head over here the stage
left and then he went over there and
talked to the head of the woman and she
talked back to him and then he brought
the two halves back together opened the
box and now popped the woman full form
no blood he cut her in half and he put
it back together you're saying
it was just an illusion no it wasn't i
saw with my own eyes i was there you
weren't even there so again you're
attacking his reality he's going to
resist he's going to fight you all right
so what you do is you offer him a better
perception you say hey listen i hear
what you're saying
but could it be possible that just maybe
out of those 50 women that raised their
hands and he picked one
maybe she works for him
maybe he planted her in the audience she
knows the trick she travels to every
show around the country with them and
when she gets in the box there's a pair
of mannequin legs laying on the floor of
the box that are wearing the same
stockings and same shoes that she has on
she picks him up shows him out the hole
when he says move your feet she shakes
those things and then she brings her own
legs up under her chest
so her whole body is on that half of the
box so the saw doesn't even touch her
and obviously when he separates the two
halves
the feet are over there now she can't
move them so he has to distract your
attention by going over here so you're
not looking at those feet and he's
talking to the head and she's talking
back of course when he brings them back
together she pulls the dummy legs leaves
him on the floor of the box she climbs
out
and then your brother says
hmm
you know i guess that would be the only
way that would work you've offered him a
better perception and that perception
then becomes his reality so don't attack
somebody's reality regardless of what it
is even if you know it to be false give
them a better perception and allow them
to resonate with it because it's always
better when somebody comes to the
conclusion i've been wrong maybe this is
something i need to think about yeah
this will work it's a perfect example of
not silencing people's ideas but giving
them better ideas and this is what the
answer to censorship has been exactly
and uh you know so daryl always talks
about how much he listens when he starts
a dialogue and doesn't even try to you
know push ideas at the people that he's
engaging with different extremists or
whatnot
would you agree with that statement
absolutely and let me just give you an
example of that okay so
i'm interviewing a clan leader white
supremacist right
and i ask you know how can you hate me
you don't even know me you know all you
see is this
come in my room five minutes ago and and
you've already determined you know
whatever you determine well mr davis you
know black people are prone to crime and
that is evidenced by the fact that there
are more blacks in prison than white
people now i'm just sitting here
listening to this guy he's calling me a
criminal
and um but he's right
he's a hundred percent right the data
and the uh
statistics show that there are more
blacks in prison than white people
so that feeds what he already thinks he
knows the data right
but he does not go to find out why does
that data show that
uh he doesn't realize there may be an
imbalance in our judicial system that
send black people to prison for longer
periods of time than white people who've
committed the same crime all right so i
just listen to him right because when he
walks in that room and he sees me i'm
the enemy his wall goes up his ears are
like this you know he's ready to defend
whatever his stance is
so i'm just listening and then he goes
and say you know uh black people are
inherently lazy uh they always have
their hand out for a freebie uh they're
always trying to scam the government
welfare programs and all that kind of
stuff so now he's caught he's called me
a criminal now he's calling me lazy
and i'm just sitting here listening i'm
not pushing back
and then he says
uh and black people are born with
smaller brains
and the larger the brain the more
capacity for intelligence the smaller
the brain the lower the iq so now i'm
being called stupid now it's what
he says that this is evidenced by the
fact that every year the data shows that
uh black high school students
consistently scored lower on the sats
than not white kids do
again he's 100 correct that does show
that right but he doesn't realize why
all right uh where do most black kids in
this country go to school in the inner
city where do most white kids go to
school in the suburbs it is a fact
suburban schools are better funded they
have better facilities better teachers
etc i will guarantee you white kids who
go to school in the inner city can score
just as low as those black kids if not
some lower black kids who go to school
in the suburbs can score just as high as
the white kids if not higher it has
absolutely nothing to do with the color
of this of the student's skin or the
size of the student's brain but has
everything to do with the educational
system in which that child is enrolled
of course he won't go to research that
because the data already supports what
he already believes that i'm inferior so
now he's called me all these things
i've already done my research on him i
know this guy sitting across from me
just barely made it out of high school i
have a college degree so do i throw that
in his face no but because i sat there
and listened to him that wall is coming
down
because you cannot impart information to
somebody when the wall is up it's like
hitting a brick wall you want that wall
to come down and then the ears open up
so now he's exhausted all his vitriol
and now he's wondering like how come
this black person isn't pushing up
against me like most of them do and he's
curious as to what i think about what he
just said so now the wall is down and he
feels compelled to reciprocate because i
sat there and listened to him insult me
so now it's my turn i could go on the
offense and say no you are the one who's
a criminal you're the one hanging black
men from trees and dragging them behind
pickup trucks and bombing their churches
and i would be 100 correct because the
clan has over 100 year history of doing
that but if i did that that wall would
go right back up so i don't want that to
happen i want to keep the wall down and
let him hear what i'm saying so i said
you know so rather than go on the
offense i go on the defense
and i say listen i hear what you're
saying however i don't have a criminal
record and i'm as black as anybody
you've ever seen
so
i don't have a criminal record i've
never been on welfare
as far as my brain size goes i've never
measured the size of my brain but i'm
sure it's the same size as anybody
else's and as far as my s.a.t scores go
they got me into college now i already
know that he doesn't have a college
degree i do does it make me a better
person than him no but it gives me a
better experience right so i let him
know this he goes home
and he thinks just like we all do at the
end of the day we reflect on what we did
during the day he thinks man i just had
a three hour conversation with a black
guy you know we didn't come to blows and
what that daryl guy said
it makes sense oh but he's black
but what he said was true but he's black
so they're having a cognitive dissonance
yeah right and they struggle with that
for a while and then they have that
dilemma i got to make my mind what am i
going to do so the dilemma is do i
disregard whatever color he is
and believe the truth because i know it
to be true and change my ideological
direction
or do i consider the color of his skin
and continue living a lie
in most cases people will follow the
truth but then there will be those who
don't want to give up the power or the
notoriety or whatever and they will
follow the lie well the way you're doing
is brilliant because you're you're doing
it so patiently
and contrary to the way most people
handle arguments most people handle
arguments by trying to shut down the
other person's argument and [ __ ] all
over them instead of trying to what
you're saying offer an alternative
perspective which is really probably the
only way to get people to think about
things in a different light and joe that
comes from the fact that i've done a lot
of travel okay i've been exposed to
people from all over the world and we
all got along we all got along we told
the story on the podcast the first time
you hear about not even understanding
racist exactly until you were a child
because you grew up overseas right
exactly and we got so i saw that so i
saw something that they have not seen
right and that's why i want to share
that with them vicariously to let them
know no it's you know the whole every
white person
uh in the world is not like every white
person in this country every black
person in the world is not like every
black person in this country you know uh
there are white people over in france
like in the 1940s and 50s a lot of black
americans moved to france to live some
even gave up their u.s citizenship
because the french people were treating
them as equals they didn't see color you
know
and those french people were a lot more
white than the white people here in this
country who might be missing something
else so you know people need to see in
fact my favorite quote of all time is by
mark twain or otherwise known as samuel
clemens it's called the travel quote and
mark twain said quote unquote travel is
fatal to prejudice bigotry and
narrow-mindedness and many of our people
need it sorely on these accounts broad
wholesome charitable views of men and
things cannot be acquired by vegetating
in one little corner of the earth all
one's lifetime that guy was so good
wasn't he he had so many great quotes
exactly isolation and so sam harris
actually did a study that we talked
about in the in the paper
about he did a neuro imaging study of
people being exposed to political
beliefs different from their own and
actually looked at people's brains when
they were going through this experience
and they actually talked about this
thing called the backfire effect which
is sort of what you're talking about
when the wall's up
and so they sort of detected that
interestingly um and i forget the exact
name of the study but it's it's it's in
the footnotes
so
i think the patience is
it
that it's long term
you're not changing someone's mind like
in five minutes of you know
chattering on in comment sections or
you know yelling at someone at the
dinner table like that that you barely
know like daryl knows how to create
long-term relationships and not be like
thirsty for them to change their mind
like it's just by like look we're here
we're we're hanging out whether it's a
network or you know offline or online
network doesn't really matter and so i
think the backfire effect that that sam
found and that we're sort of talking
about with walls going up is very real
and that's why
it's just it has to be long term
you know but daryl i'm just thinking
while i'm listening here like these
conversations that you've had with these
white supremacists and neo-nazis how
amazing would it be if that was a
podcast it is if you
know what i'm saying if you sat down
with those people from the beginning
from first meeting them and see that
conversation play out that would be very
related i've got some of that yeah where
where i've sat down with some of these
people while they were still in and now
i'm sitting down with them now that
they're out some of them even come on on
my lecture tours with me and stand on
stage with me and speak out against
their former do you have videos of these
conversations yeah some of them yeah god
are they online uh some of them i think
are but if not i can send you some i
think those videos would be a great tool
for someone that's maybe trapped but
like at least partially open-minded
where they have this like view of things
like maybe i'm incorrect about this
maybe i need to reevaluate yeah you know
like that but as a podcast that would be
brilliant
you